how's it going citizens of the reject
Nation it is John Beck in the saddle
once again for a solo movie reaction and
this week we are checking out another
Disney animated classic that I
completely missed out on at the time
Disney's Tarzan don't call him George of
the Jungle yeah all I know about this
really is is that there's a bunch of
Phil Collins music in it that's my main
association with Tarzan going into it
but I'm very excited to catch back up it
was 1999 man it was the New Millennium
Y2K man the Grid's going down kids ask
your parents or excuse me the new
willennium yeah anyway if you could
leave a like on this video that would be
very much appreciated as well subscribe
to the channel and hit that notification
Bell so you can be updated every time
something new and Nifty drops on the
channel that you might be interested in
and as always if you want to get the
full experience see everything that
doesn't make these reaction highlights
come on over to patreon.com the real
rejects grab your own copy of Tarzan
sync up with with me and enjoy The Full
Experience along with everything else we
got over at the patreon tons of shows
and movies over there check out Lilo and
Stitch just recently did the Emperor's
New Groove Roxy stryer and I just did a
reaction to Puss and Boots The Last Wish
tons of Family Fare here at the real
Rejects and uh yeah without further Ado
let's swing into this
Tarzan
swings man not like that though it rolls
and bumper
[Music]
oh really getting right to it all right
wow
thank you
[Music]
God the lighting is
beautiful
[Music]
oh man we're getting right to it
nice match cut
[Music]
so adorable
is that gonna be home tree
[Music]
foreign
guy
[Music]
nice little parallel too I'm cutting
back and forth laying the foundations of
their eventual inroad to bonding
[Music]
peace run little buddy
oh
it's gone
[Music]
what's about to happen to little
Tarzan's parents
so loaded by the beauty of all this I
almost forgot this is a Disney movie
after all although it would be fair they
just went pretty hard on that
combination child animal devouring rest
in peace little guy
thank you
this is the tool of the enemy
oh no
careful Murdoch that's your name until I
learned your real name
the body language
[Music]
foreign
young child animation babies are the
best babies
you're gonna have one for the kids
foreign
[Music]
God
Let the Bodies get cold
[Music]
oh that looks
thank you
oh my goodness
it's Focus wreck
[Music]
thank God for diapers
oh
geez
[Music]
get to the lifeboats
what's up Phil
oh yeah
God just this Melody has me back in the
90s boy
squeaky looking okay that's what it is
you look like a troll doll with that
hairdo I'm going to be as much
Carla it won't replace the one
[Music]
week oh Carla I cannot let you put our
family in danger does he look dead
was it alone
are you sure
did you poke the bodies kirchak I know
he'll be a good son I said he could stay
oh that doesn't make him my son oh no
I'm gonna call him
Tarzan hey
I got a lifetime of daddy issues ahead
of you Tarzan just
hold it tight
from all around you
this guy
you up there singing fall on so small
you seem so strong
my arms will hold you keep you safe and
warm it's beautiful
it's the animation environments
yes you'll be
nice
get us a grown-up montage
ah
the classic animal call
[Music]
s those little sprinklings of a Fantasia
how cool would it be if they did another
one of those huh
[Music]
you've just come up with your own sound
hmm
this guy is a Mean Mug in the whole
movie can I go
oh stop hitting yourself the fun has
arrived thank you very much whoa this
little Bart Simpson in there
hi guys tell me I'm not looking at the
hairless Wonder
well Turk said I could come along if I
could keep up it's got some hair
eyes they need a little convincing
what am I gonna do uh you gotta go get a
half an elephant hat
the game is afoot
[Music]
[Applause]
oh someone hurt him
sure I felt that
[Music]
me Mommy
her patients
[Laughter]
there are no piranhas in my butt oh
I guess the tail would make the most
sense the most obvious tuft of hair also
there are no piranhas in my butt snuck
right past me I see you out there Disney
[Music]
ugh of course
God the perspective he's dead
should have thought about this
[Music]
having like Lion King flashbacks over
here
nice little Frankenstein right there you
got the hair is that what this is all
about I got a whole tale of them hey
it happened well
um it's sort of a long it's involved
because what happened it was a weird
what happened
oh God it was my fault her check
you almost killed someone ugh
he's only a child that's no excuse Carla
you can't keep defending him you will
never learn he will never be one of us
the other kids were involved this is
just like Avatar the way of water you'll
earn his respect lowak the spider is
basically just kid Tarzan with an air
mass
oh
it's not the answer Tarzan
what are you doing something problematic
close your eyes
what do you feel
my heart
your heart see we're exactly the same
I don't care what evolution says
[Music]
oh that sound effect
s oh boy
he's always there to just be like he
will never live up
[Music]
to be wise
that you seek
and it's
adapt to the Animal Kingdom learn from
every faction this is cool
go mutt Lang or whatever Shia LaBeouf's
name was in Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
a little Karma Miranda look for you it's
interesting too how this is reminding me
of of certain other Disney animated
movies but in a way that's like not as
in your face as it would be now you know
foreign
[Music]
wow what a beautiful water effect jeez
e
[Laughter]
oh wow wow
[Music]
yes
oh man I remember that that shot of the
trailer
I just felt all that energy coming right
at me just now okay
[Music]
all right Tarzan this is where you get
your vengeance
[Music]
please don't tell me that if Tarzan
saves him he's just gonna look even
further down on him
[Music]
oh now you just making him mad
wow
nice shot
oh geez
he's just wearing his skin
wow wow it really just marked that
leopard
[Music]
ah he really did kill that Beast
oh no what was that
hey it wasn't me I swear okay now you
know maybe it was everyone let's move no
come on just finish the moment as
beautifully tired I was like right right
on the verge of tears and then and then
we came in
I love this music too
no shade to Phil Collins but the
percussion music is great too and then I
remember that Phil Collins is a
percussionist so he probably played
these parts as well anyway nope yeah
good job Phil
it was created
for me of course it was
oh my God
I thought I saw something
is that is that peace do no no uh
I need to bring back words like
hullabaloo nanny
do you think the Beast nearby whether we
could be here there's the evidence you
know
yes it's the whole Kong Studios these
are wild beasts it would sort of tear
your head off than look at you on the
contrary Mr Clayton Daddy's theory is
that these are social creatures
like us
social creatures
which all the class was about
Curious George and the woman in the
yellow dress
no no don't give me those crocodile
tears what would your parents have to
say
oh no
[Music]
Rafiki why
so hands off my lady Crush
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's a very 90s gag but without put me
down put it down pick me up pick me up
whoa
oh my goodness
gotta imagine this is 3D
the bowling pins sound effect a little
90s classic
oh yeah I remember that oh God
oh boy
hmm
[Music]
wow great portrayal of just the weight
and physics Ace
yeah they're like a couple moments here
that like I would have at least seen in
the trailer and I haven't seen like
since 99 that are like buried in my
sense memories and that splits moment
was one of them it's like no context
just
so it's fascinating about going back and
catching up with these you know
closer please don't
ah yeah this little piggy went to Market
oh
oh the curvature of his fingers
oh my oh oh my
[Music]
God oh dear oh dear oh dear
it's a lovely heartbeat it's very nice
it's a very nice friendly heartbeat it's
very nice who do you speak very nice
Tarzan
see
oh I
I know
Jane
Clayton
oh boy
can you take me to my Camp
um
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's a cute little like monkey see
monkey do element with Tarzan and Jane
as well I see you Disney hey watch
everybody looking at
it
oh no
[Music]
Miss Potts what do they do to you chip
oh man look at this
oh I know it's satisfying isn't it
let me hear it big fella
now hit it yep where's the beat
[Music]
let's do it
ah yeah
[Music]
dude this is your Mighty Joe Young show
right here just bring this back to the
States and then let them perform you
know like one of those found object
bands
could be on the Vegas Strip in a week
[Music]
in a happy mood
oh my God
he smells Tarzan on her
oh no
yeah
yes hey hey
you buy a Flying Wild Man in a lion
cloth
[Laughter]
like wild man in the loincloth they need
us no harm coach act you may be willing
to risk our safety but I'm not why are
you threatened by anyone different from
you
[Music]
no
information
[Music]
somebody remixed that hello
Tarzan let's see what you mean about
those personal boundaries what's he
doing why would he come over and talk to
me
where are the gorillas
I'm trying so hard not to make a
gorilla's joke every time this happens I
apologize
cool
old-timey projector
I love art within art because like they
have to animate to look slightly
different than just the what is
presented as reality ah how lovely
[Music]
See Jane love
hey
[Music]
Cinema Tarzan
it's a misty morning these gorillas
ah it's almost like the enchanted Tiki
Room Birds
[Music]
as I feel
right now
all the birds sing words and the flowers
croon
ah
I'm gonna go back home and sign up for
like an aerial shroud dancing class or
something we
we can't what
Tarzan kirchak
uh my dad says no
it's just a roided out looking depiction
of a gorilla
a lot of these like learning montages
that they're having him do
what
uh you're about to learn a valuable
lesson
and set traps for the Beast shot my way
through the entire jungle
obviously England today come home
tomorrow
be very difficult to come back ever but
you belong with us we
pull Jane must stay with Tarzan oh I
can't oh
if only she could have spent more time
with the gorillas she's so disappointed
crushed really
if Jane sees gorillas
she stays say that's why she came isn't
it take Jane to see gorillas
[Music]
Snipes sir get the boys together there's
gonna be a change in plan
ah that guy look kind of like me
I'm asking you as a friend
[Music]
actually I thought that dress was rather
slimming on you oh really
now you look great
oh no
don't please he's gonna murder them
though you know how kerchek is
I'm gonna beat his chest and Crush those
two
[Music]
I gotta imagine it's probably subtly
difficult to do it with that shadowing
the dappled light through the trees
she's my mother
huh
oh boy
what what's happening cast on over here
better not ruin this
WOW
lovely perspective
[Music]
oh cool
it was up to two years
sure oh this is wonderful Mr Clayton
look look social grooming social
grooving
oh
yes yes
little faces
[Music]
he's teaching all the swear words
what did I say did I say says some
salacious change days with Tarzan
oh wow
oh god
oh that is not a good look on his face
oh no yeah yeah yeah
oh
bad bad bad bad bad bad bad bad bad
no no no no no no
okay quickly honey
[Music]
oh boy I'm sorry I asked you to protect
our family and you betrayed us all
these hands yeah oh curses human hands
come with me there's something I should
have shown
oh no are are there bodies just still
doing here decomposing
oh
is this me
and this is my father
and
never mind oh
so great it's a great character
did everything you could and did what
you thought was right
oh
oh my
no matter where I go
you will always be my mother oh
oh
I love their body language back and
forth
[Music]
that is a beautiful coast and Tide
animation hey goodbye yeah well good
job no
what are you looking at I'm gonna miss
him too
[Music]
acknowledge my feelings
everyone's going to want to meet you
Kings and scientists and famous writers
yes and I'll be with Jane oh God
thank you
yes
Jane
[Music]
and these guys didn't seem trustworthy
oh geez
[Music]
yeah you're in a steel world now I have
you to thank my boy
couldn't have done it without you lock
him up with the others
he sounded like like he was in trouble
but I don't care what no I had it with
you and your emotional constipation
my pipe down and hang on tight we've got
a boat to catch yes your courage
[Music]
freaking guy
I guess maybe if they're olfactories are
that good maybe it could be like a
smell-o-vision Clayton betrayed us all I
betrayed my family what is this world
coming true
yes yes
yeah
childhood just like an elephant tantar
tetar
oh
God always with the hacking slash
all right
with that red light from the flare too
so angry
come on t
F come on t
ight
yes
[Music]
the full Fury of the elephants
I came home get the hell out of my sight
JK I'm happy
that he's happy
you there but you can back to the boat I
love the detail too this hair keeps
falling out of place and keeps having to
sweep it back
unlock your training Jane
leave the charge my dude
[Music]
oh geez
no
come on man yeah
how can I get rid of you rounding up
your little eight family will be all too
easy
oh boy nah man
you're in Tarzan's territory now
yes yes yes
[Music]
oh foreign
oh no
oh
wow there is there's a circle of life in
this movie
[Music]
just a flesh wound
forgive me
forgive me for not understanding eyes
our family will look to you now no
take care of them
my son oh
foreign
[Music]
send you a new station
thank you
the leader
say goodbye
[Music]
no come on
hey is he got the other one I don't have
feeling that you should stay I belong in
England with you with people when I
uh
listen to Mother Nature
[Music]
no or okay
no the kiss thanks for getting my glove
oh oh
[Music]
that's probably the first you probably
taught him what a kiss was just now kept
him oh
after all people get lost in the jungle
every day
[Music]
go for it why not
oh nice little transition
got her jungle Garb on
hey everyone gets a loin Club
[Music]
[Applause]
well done
nicely done Kevin Limon Chris buck
and everybody else okay Edgar Rice
Burroughs there you go all right I was
thinking like where
I know they referenced Kipling and other
people who who would have certainly been
writing about you know
adventure and the world's Uncharted
incontinence across the world okay Tony
Goldwyn mini driver there you go Glenn
Close
interesting Rosie O'Donnell there you go
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay and that was
Wayne Knight too all right yeah I
thought I recognized his voice for sure
Clayton was Brian blessed all right
yeah bad call there not not peace do but
still a a good voice cast overall very
very much so I missed these two the way
they would do these old credits where
it's like yeah you have the different
characters and you know who worked on
them in terms of the animation The Voice
kind of all together like you know
instead of just having the credited
voices you know have every character
credited for all the people who brought
them to life I think that's kind of neat
you know like a neat earmark of
especially this kind of animation and I
feel like at the time this you know at
the time this came granted I didn't see
this at the time but you know like
anything I would have seen at the time
we were at credits we were staying for
the credits family before it was cool
you know but uh same time I wouldn't
have really picked up on that back then
whereas yeah now I've come to quite
appreciate it and and you know you don't
see it the same way in a CG animated
thing but
Phil Collins boy
I remember that again being like a
really big deal about this movie that
was like even at the time I wasn't 100
aware of you know
the music world the same way I am now
then but yeah just for whatever reason I
think growing up on enough Genesis Peter
Gabriel and Phil Collins stuff in
general just from what my folks would
have been listening to yeah just the
idea that he did this movie seemed like
a big like they're they're I think that
was a market at it heavily you know in
that regard but uh it's interesting too
because there was that whole thing about
sting you know being supposed to do the
music for Emperor's New Groove and then
that falling through oh that big old
drum fill yeah just that that idea that
he was supposed to do the music for that
and I think they kept what like one song
for the credits but it almost feels like
an earmark of this time as notable
musicians and rockers and whatever else
from you know us that 80s especially you
know peak in the 80s kind of era then at
the end of the 90s yeah you're doing the
kind of big high profile Disney projects
yeah there's some of that little jittery
like more genesisy stuff in the
background oh my goodness what a what a
journey what a trip what a delightful
ride let's jump in let's talk about it
what a lovely Adventure that was that
was very very fun and uh yeah I don't
have the greatest uh familiarity with
the Edgar Rice Burroughs novel I know
that Tarzan the story of Tarzan uh has
been adapted several times uh you know
I've got that passing familiarity with
the ideas of Tarzan and Jane and you
know the various other works that kind
of bleed over into that your jungle
books your Georges of the Jungle
Etc
um but yeah I thought this Made For A
really lovely uh sort of blend of ideas
that I've come to expect from Disney
animated fair you know because in some
ways this is a story of love and romance
and coming of age and there's certainly
a musical element at play but there is
also a quality that is a little bit more
um just removed from traditional
dialogue it splits the difference but I
feel like a movie like this in a setting
like this sets you up for a lot of
interesting opportunities to do more
visual storytime telling do things that
rely more on the body language of the
characters and the subtle Expressions
they're in and I think this did a nice
job of bridging both in some ways I mean
I could have not not that it's a
complaint at all but uh you know in some
ways I could have gone even more you
know toward the side of just you know
showing and actions and body language
and all that stuff but I thought they
managed to realize this African jungle
in a really
breathtaking and gorgeous way much of
the time and I would be curious to know
what sort of animation technology was at
play here just because there is so much
in the ways of uh beautiful landscapes
Beautiful Textures when you're whooshing
and he's like surfing through the trees
like the perspectives that they put you
in these first person povs or these uh
you know tracking shots where you're
looking around at you know the vastness
of these you know systems of trees and
canopies and whatnot and uh yeah just
the way that they you know realize these
exotic and foreign locations especially
in this era of Disney movies is just so
so so so gorgeous and like some of those
water textures especially as he's
climbing up that face of the waterfall
there and there's like one particular
rock that just has like a jet flowing
over it uh yeah this is such a beautiful
and sort of old school it's like this
came out in 99 line but because of where
this is set and the ERA this is set
there is something about it that does
kind of feel like you know again a
painting from an exotic land that you
don't just have like a photograph to
access you know uh and so yeah I also
appreciated that in the dialogue when
they're talking about you know how the
Apes move and how they behave I could
feel you know the writer is pretty much
putting in their research to the direct
dialogue of some of these characters
um but yeah I just really enjoyed uh the
way that this kicked things off you know
you're watching this you know dual
sequence of tragic events unfold with
this beautiful shipwreck and again the
fire the light coming off the ship and
just the intensity of the Peril there as
you know it capsizes and they have to
swim to Shore and you know slowly uh
they they use the pieces of the ship to
Fashion themselves the sort of house and
then you see on the gorilla side of
things you know they're bringing up
their kids and you see just kind of the
status quo before for this jaguar attack
uh no leopard I should say this leopard
attack and then watching this you know
this again dual tragedy where you know
you start off with the Shipwreck and and
you know Tarzan little little Tarzan and
his family finding their way to shore
barely scrapes it by and then has to you
know build a new life literally out of
the remnants I thought that was a really
kind of beautiful detail that they make
this tree house out of the wreckage of
the ship and create something quite
charming and you know new that wasn't
there before and uh you know that's a
nice metaphor for sort of what's about
to happen in just the lives of everybody
who are gonna be on this journey because
yeah you know as this new family is
starting between kala and kerchek you
know tragedy awaits them as well and so
then you have uh the leopard attack and
I love the transition into that you get
this sort of looming face uh in front of
the tree house and then you know sort of
cutting over to the baby gorilla you
know following the what is it like a
frog or something off into the woods and
then getting into this you know intense
scrape that ultimately ends in tragedy
and you know watching I I really like
the way that they chose to portray all
these events because especially throwing
in you into the movie it is all visual
it is all just intensity and energy and
body language and things like that and a
nice again just parallel look at the
struggles the triumphs and tragedies of
these two groups that are about to be
sort of fused by this you know
intermittent figure in little Tarzan and
yeah you know watching after all that
you know after they survived the
Shipwreck and everything and they built
this house only to then be devoured by
this uh you know leopard and the way
they showed that too the way they
portrayed that it's like you know you
have the baby gorilla you know taken off
screen but you feel the grief in its
parents and then you know seeing as kala
is sort of drawn to the tree house and
and then finds the crying baby and the
remnants of his pair like that that was
the moment you know at the beginning of
this where I was like oh oh we're
getting real like we're not shying away
again from the circle of life and you
know the ways in which tragedy can be
just part of a food chain or it can just
be due to the elements and and whatever
else and and the different sort of
emotions and and and feelings that arise
from that and I like that you know there
there is you know that unspoken history
and obviously you have this element of
the secret kala not telling him where he
comes from or that there are others like
him out there leaving that for him to
discover and the sort of conundrum that
that represents especially later on in
the movie where she does finally have to
reveal the truth to him and uh and and
for his compact Act of a movie as this
is because I think there are sort of two
modes uh that a lot of these uh Disney
films can fall into for me personally as
a viewer I feel like some of them really
slam dunk the blend of brevity but also
you know fluidity and and breathability
where you know some of these movies I'll
finish up and be like damn that was only
like an hour 15 20 minutes but they
jam-packed that with richness and here I
think there is a lot of richness on
display but this is one of the ones I
would say that does feel maybe a touch
more brief in its overall encompassing
of every you know thing it's got going
on within its uh story and themes and
all that like there's certain
aspects of this movie that I just would
have spent more time on it's not even
necessarily I think they're missing
because like in the plot all this stuff
is there
um but yeah there are just certain turns
and certain developments I maybe would
have liked to have spent more time in
because there is such a rich sort of
Aura and emotionality to a lot of what's
happening on screen but that being said
I do appreciate that they didn't take
many if any cheap opportunities to draw
out melodrama it's like you know when
it's late in the movie but when she
finally reveals the truth to Tarzan
about his parents and takes him to their
tree house and all that stuff like I
feel like that could have turned into a
much more flippant and over dramatic
scene and there is definitely you know a
toll that that takes and and the choice
the weight of the choice not to reveal
you know this to him not to reveal his
true origin to him is a heavy one and it
is something that you know isn't
entirely College Choice even and it just
represents an interesting human
conundrum and a very relatable decision
in again her concealing this information
from him and it's stuff like that that's
that's quite interesting and two just
Tarzan in general is an interesting
figure because he does exist between
groups and I like that so much of the
movie you know you watch him grow and
come of age
um but it's not really overly about
whether or not he is accepted by the gr
it's not like about him just always
trying to win the acceptance of his
found family you know it's like there's
certainly absolutely that element with
kirchak
um but yeah I like that you see him you
know once he's grown up a little bit
from being a baby he's a young kid you
see him out and about you know carefree
and certainly a little care less uh in
that you know he's prone to you know
causing a ruckus and because he doesn't
have the exact same uh just you know
Instinct in Mobility as everybody else
around him yeah he does have to find his
own way of carving a place out here and
you do have the other kids picking on
him work you know sending him on that
wild goose chase to find the elephant
hair as a means of ditching him and not
having to deal with spending time with
him but then the actual friendship that
comes out of that and I thought like you
know that was handled in such a way
where it's like you know once the
hijinks have ensued and you know he's
freaked out all the elephants in the
watering hole and they think it's a
freaking piranha situation once that's
done you know he's pretty much got Turks
respect and then the next time we see uh
you know an older Tarzan clearly most
people it seem like have accepted him
and so like that was a nice thing where
it's like okay cool it's it doesn't have
to be about like we've seen that movie
and that movie happens in that interlude
you know where he is the young Tarzan
but as he grows up he comes more into
his own element in that little nugget of
like yeah if you want to you know hang
with us you gotta you gotta be able to
keep up and then watching as he develops
his own ways of not only being able to
keep up but being able to stay ahead in
in certain respects of you know his
family of the pack uh you know swinging
through through the vines and and
surfing through the branches of the
trees and everything and the way that
they realize just the
the Primal uh just excitement and awe
and wonder and really natural beauty of
that is something to behold like I again
loved love loved the aura of the Jungle
of the textures uh there's so many just
backdrops and environments that could
all be you know clipped and hung up on a
wall somewhere as again just these
beautiful depictions of an exotic
location
and uh and I really liked the way that
they for a lot of parts of this lets you
live in you know
something that I mean the Apes all speak
you know like and and I didn't even
think about that during the movie but
there is that certain quality of like
you've got Tarzan like learning English
from you know uh Jane and uh and you
know the professor and I keep wanting to
call him Conrad but that would be uh
Clayton uh you know there is that kind
of it's not it's not a flaw but yeah I
do think it's kind of funny it's like
you have him and you have the way he
speaks with the gorillas and stuff like
that which I have to imagine is probably
stylized like they're probably in
reality they're all you know grunting at
each other because he's teaching her how
to speak ape
um but even that even the way that he
then has to go and learn about the human
society like he gets to be a fish out of
water in both respects and I think that
is kind of a nice Dynamic for this
because it keeps a lot of things sort of
fresh and interesting and there's always
a certain sense of Whimsy and Discovery
in places that for us you know with the
jungle are foreign and then in places
for us as especially people in Western
Society are very familiar and so yeah
watching as uh he meets them and you
know comes upon their camp and they
teach him about the world and they have
this projector machine and they're
showing him all these like um I mean I
in the moment they look like they were
supposed to be like line drawings or
something like that but I don't know if
that was just stylized to separate
the make the idea it's like when they
show him the picture of his family the
portrait of his family which I assume
was supposed to be like a photograph
it's still like shaded and drawn with a
slightly different style than the rest
of the movie is so as to give it that
additional quality of being a captured
image
rather than just you know the reality at
hand and so I thought they did nicely to
yeah separate those as well with the art
style and to create this sort of far-off
Wonder and even though yeah I mean it
does kind of breach the idea of like
should Tarzan go uh to civilized society
where he maybe belongs or should Jane
stay here with him and it's stuff like
that that I think could have used maybe
a little bit more of a perilous back and
forth like once things get going with
Clayton in them and has become very
clear like At first I I kind of liked
you kind of always know that that guy's
gonna take a heal turn pretty strongly
he just oozes that kind of vibe
um but yeah like in in the initial
moments where they're all just sort of
getting to know the place like it is
kind of a fun uh you know sort of uh
combination of sensibilities and then
yeah once you have you know the ruse
Clayton's ruse revealed and he's got
these like sketchy boat worker pirate
guy guys who are then going to basically
poach and capture all these gorillas to
take back and put in the zoo or whatever
you know once we get there things get
pretty perilous pretty quick and then
there's a lot of action up until the
resolution and so it's things like that
it's like even with uh kerchek I thought
maybe we could have spent a little bit
more time in that cathartic moment of
his finally earning the approval and
finally showing his father figure who
has never accepted him just the sheer
level of dedication I brought these
people here yes I have clearly found a
romantic Connection in this woman and
yet who am I going to fight for when the
chips are down to you guys and I thought
they made again A really lovely moment
out of that I will say though everything
with kala and that entire relationship I
thought was really beautiful and really
nicely handled and I'm glad that I guess
if any relationship got that much warmth
and attention and just intimate time
spent it is that one and I gotta applaud
them for that but yeah that's one of
those things or even tantor I feel feel
like uh tantor rushing in and you know
helping uh you know free them from the
hull of the ship nice moment sure and a
great uh you know sort of uh triumphant
sort of team up moment for uh tantor and
Turk but at the same time you know it's
like I feel as though this is even the
point of the movie but it's like that
seems like it wanted to be some kind of
big cathartic like oh yeah there you go
tent or way to rise above being a a you
know neurotic sort of sheepish character
that we saw you as as a child but I
don't know I mean when we see tantor a
little more grown up it doesn't seem
that cowardly anymore so it's little
things like that that I think could have
been finessed a little bit better but I
do think that the voice cast especially
did a really nice job I wouldn't have
picked out Tony Goldwyn
um and and Minnie Driver I mean I've
certainly heard her in in uh several
things and seen her in several things
didn't obviously pick her out here but I
thought the two of them did a really
nice job in their contrasting roles
because she has to be so proper and so
you know uh loquacious in a way uh you
know she has to sort of embody this
ideal and very lovely but also kind of
opposite uh point from Tarzan who is
yeah uh very much
a character of physicality and body
language and action and who yes does
have you know words then and speech but
you know that's not his foremost means
of communication and I thought Tony
Goldwin managed to inhabit that place in
a really nice way and so you know thus
took a character that isn't again very
little loquacious kind of a laconic
character
um but you know put a lot of Personality
into the lines and made every line count
and so yeah definitely hats off to the
both of them just for kind of anchoring
and leading this uh Glenn Close I
thought did a great job very warm
presences kala uh Lance Hendrickson nice
choice for kirchak kirchak I mean you
know again a character that I think
could have been given a little more meat
just show I think just seeing who this
guy was and and getting a little bit
more of his perspective I mean you could
head Cannon it it's probably not that
hard even I mean he's he says a few of
his main motivations certainly
throughout the movie but that is a
character yeah where it's like man I
would like to know more about the life
of this person so that I can feel like
the odds between him and Tarzan aren't
so one-sided like you again you get him
and you get his trepidation and
especially having trun this territory in
other you know pieces of media not
unlike this you know yeah you can gather
what's going on here but you know it's
one of those things that I think could
have been finessed just a a little bit
better in the emotional resolution like
I feel like the first half has this
really beautiful sense of sensory
exploration and then you know once you
really realize what uh Clayton's plan is
and and hats off to Brian blessed too
not peace Stu I got that one wrong but I
thought he had a great you know press
visits and really embodied yeah your
quintessential uh uh you know
Adventurer slash enterprising uh sort of
conniving character who certainly comes
across as very dashing and proper but is
also a Cutthroat at the end of the day
uh Wayne Knight as tantor Rosie
O'Donnell is Turk and and keeping that
sort of Trope too alive I feel like of
having at least one character with just
sort of a ringer accent
um but you know yeah very fun presences
to have overall and I mean that too I
mean I feel like you know them as as
best friends I think just watching the
reality of that unfold was really nice
watching their friendship grow on screen
just through the visual the action the
Thematic stuff was nice but even that
was something where I was like you know
I wanted to be a little bit more
endeared to the relationship of Tarzan
and Turk because there is that moment
where Turk is like that's my best friend
right there you know and and there is
definitely that quality there is
definitely some of that there but that's
that's another one of those there
another one of like a few different
things that I feel like could have been
explored just a little bit more
intimately as time goes on because I
think that would have also just made you
know the sort of debate it's like you
know when Jane is trying to compel
Tarzan to go back to uh you know London
with her uh yeah there's sort of
no real debate for me I'm like yeah you
Stars Tarzan belongs here we should stay
here you know he's totally in his
element here and uh this is totally his
world and I feel like you are in Gross
in this world you should probably stay
here too
um so I didn't really feel personally
sort of pulled uh uh in both of the
directions of that argument so I mean I
think they did well enough in the way
that they realized the characters in the
relationships but I think they could
have tugged that much you know more on
our heart strings
if we spent maybe just a little bit more
time in a couple of these relationships
um as things were to unfold but as it
stands again I thought this was a really
fun and enjoyable movie with just a a
beautiful sense of Aura a beautiful
animation and A really lovely just
overall Aura of Adventure and Discovery
clearly uh heavily researched both in
terms of the gorillas and the body
language and then adapting that to
Tarzan as a human character but
emulating those uh physicalities and
those sensibilities and whatnot and uh
and yeah this just this amounted to
something that I thought was very uh
immediate and and well observed and yeah
in the tradition certainly of a Disney
animated film but I like even how this
starts off with you don't get the
full-on bumper even you get the logo but
you're already in the leaves and you're
pushing forward and then there's the
title card and then you're right into
this this ship cap sizing and I think
that kind of does clue you into the fact
that this movie is gonna move it a
pretty tight clip there aren't a lot of
scenes I feel like the stuff that gets
to breathe most is the music
um you know those are the scenes that
get the most just sort of dedicated
breathing room where yeah it's not
dialogue but obviously there's singing
happening the music is taking us into
Stage and I think those were nicely done
and realized and I think my favorite one
and I didn't even realize at the time I
I guess I would have just assumed that
Phil Collins had done the you know songs
that were obviously Phil Collins songs
with him singing on them and I didn't
realize at the time that he would have
done uh the you know the the percussion
piece when they're uh discovering and
subsequently destroying the camp and and
I thought that was perhaps my favorite
musical moment actually I mean the The
Melodies of those main songs are
certainly baked into my subconscious
from just living in this era and and
seeing the trailers at the time and and
Radio Disney being a thing you know
certainly I hadn't even thought about
them in well over a decade but those are
certainly sort of alive back there but
that that moment I thought was really
fun and gratifying because you know I
mean Phil Collins is a percussionist uh
you know there's that you know a sense
of getting to use a different part of
his repertoire but that was also a great
moment I think for a bit of you know
diabetic sound you know diegetic music
uh you know the kala sings the one you
know main song Motif as a lullaby and I
thought that was you know sort of nicely
handled and a nice way to bring the yeah
that main sort of song and Melody into
the direct reality of the story but yeah
just that that number where they're all
just grooving in the camp and they're
breaking stuff and they're just you know
Finding different kinds of percussion
and using the laundry line as like a
base you know string to keep the rhythm
going like I thought that was really fun
and inventive and something that is
perfectly suited to this medium because
of again the possibilities but also the
limitations and that was the moment that
came together in also you know being
surprising for discovering that it was
Phil Collins behind that piece
um and and yeah like they just had so
much personality it was so fun it was
stuff like that and other little more uh
Moody flourishes like with the little uh
auxiliary creatures and and butterflies
and and just like the natural phenomena
uh that are occurring you know
periodically just in this setting stuff
like that kind of reminded me of like
little sprinklings of like a Fantasia
type of vibe
um but yeah man overall I thought this
was really really fun a really uh uh you
know nice crisp telling of this
particular story and yeah even if
certain details are are a little slight
or uh a little straightforward given the
clip of the plot I still thought that
for what it is and for who it's aimed at
this was done with a lot of panache and
a lot of poise
um and yeah it's really enjoyable and a
really uh you know nice tangible
experience again like my favorite part I
think of this whole movie is just how
beautifully rendered the jungle is and
and the sheer feeling like even sitting
here at home beholding those uh
sequences where he is you know surfing
through the tree branches surfing
through the canopies uh high above the
ground below and just all these corked
screws and and twists and turns and
loops and things like that just so vital
and and so I I yeah I felt like I was
you know felt the breeze in my hair and
I felt like I was on a sort of roller
coaster for moments like that I think
that is is especially you know special
and transportive uh for something like
this for this medium so yeah guys let me
know your thoughts what did you think of
Tarzan is it one of your top favorite
Disney animated features where would you
put it where would you rank it what are
your thoughts on it overall let me know
in the comments below and uh yeah but
don't forget to like subscribe let me
know any other uh animated or otherwise
movies that you would like me to check
out and last but certainly not least
let's do it
James Smith nice
anglo-sounding name sounds like the nice
name of a of some kind of swashbuckling
Explorer settings sail across the Seven
Seas charting lands unknown and pledging
supporting the Arts
and entertainment with the plunder that
you bring back from those exotic
locations James you spell your name cool
I would be happy if I was you know to be
rolled up a pond in The Jungle by you I
would feel very comfortable bringing you
back home to my people the gorillas who
have adopted me and uh and making you
you know an honorary citizen of our land
of the reject in fact that's what you've
done you you jumped into the pledge
machine you patreoned it up and now
you're part of the you're you're a
gorilla you're like when Ace from The
Powerpuff Girls replaced Murdoch for a
while but yeah now you're one of us and
we couldn't be happier to have you
you're welcome here any and every time
James Smith thank you for sticking with
us for as long as you have I hope you
enjoyed this video or at least this
portion of the video I don't know what
kind of movies do you like James are you
an animated movie guy let me know and
then maybe next month we'll shout you
out on a different animated movie or
something different entirely who knows
but for right now what I do knows
that you knows that we love you and and
that you love us I think and uh and hey
we appreciate that very much so stay
well stay fledged and uh yeah just thank
you for all your support Hospitality
kindness
Etc and uh we'll catch you next month be
well James
[Music]